cheering crowds extravagant decorations
and even
a camel convoy it was all for donald
trump on his visit to india or
namaste trump as the onlookers chanted
he was given
a royal welcome
[Music]
of course behind all the pretty facades
poverty-stricken slums don't just go
away
people living near open sewers with no
indoor plumbing of their own
garbage everywhere but india's prime
minister is trying to make a good
impression on the leader of the world's
richest country
and a good impression he has made
america
loves india america respects
india and america will always be
faithful
and loyal friends to the indian people
but relations between washington and new
delhi haven't been so good on the trade
front
back in 2018 the u.s announced new
tariffs on steel and aluminum
a year later india was removed from the
generalized system of preferences
a special trade agreement that exempts
u.s allies from certain economic
restrictions
the country was even threatened with
secondary sanctions for buying a
russian-made
s-400 missile system hopes were high for
a new trade deal
that would have eased some of that
friction too bad it seems to have been
shelved for now
well we can have a trade deal with india
but i'm really saving the big deal for
later on we're doing a very big trade
deal with india we'll have it
i don't know if it'll be done before the
election but we'll have a very big deal
with india
the u.s wants india to lower tariffs and
also to open up
the markets in a big way to players in
the us
that's not possible for the simple
reason
india is an emerging market it's a
country that is home to
a large number of poor people a lot of
them
employed in the agriculture sector a us
finds
india's position a bit dodgy and awkward
but india has its own reasons to adopt
those measures because a primary
instinct for any indian politician
is to protect the indian market while
trump and modi couldn't see eye to eye
on trade
they had more than enough to agree on
concerning war
specifically regarding their common
enemy china both washington and india
have been fighting to curb beijing's
regional influence especially
its naval presence in the south china
sea so trump's ready to seal
a three billion dollar defense deal that
would equip india
with a number of new state-of-the-art
helicopters made in the u.s
of a as we continue to build our defense
cooperation
the united states looks forward to
providing india with some of the best
and most feared military equipment on
the planet
we make the greatest weapons ever made
airplanes missiles rockets
ships we make the best and we're dealing
now with india a lot of people believe
that china is enemy number one
because of its uh superior military
power
and for the us this is a great
deal it is to check china's growing
presence
in the indian ocean and these choppers
this helicopter
therefore would be uh useful in
containing certain threats that might
arise
in the indian ocean where china has over
more than a decade been
very aggressive only making postures
you